en fait ce sont des réactions
émotionnelles c'est la peur c'est la
panique c'est à dire on essaye de faire
quelque chose est en fait il faut faire
quelque chose de visible et c'est là où
je vais rebondir ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure finalement mettre des
aérateurs des détecteurs de co2 dans les
écoles ça va être de la responsabilité
de l'état ou des communes donc il ya
quelqu'un de désigner il faut amener de
l'argent dessus il faut amener des
ressources que la nature que l'on est
aujourd'hui imposé le match à
l'extérieur finalement ça coûte pas
grand chose à l'état c'est la
responsabilité de l'individu est
aujourd'hui à laisser circuler et
finalement l'eau mikron s'est donné la
responsabilité majoritaire aux jets à
dire aux élèves à la brutalisation
priorité dans ce we et pour revenir sur
les fermetures de frontières finalement
depuis 2005 tous les états membres de l'
oms ont signé le règlement sanitaire
international qui dit justement ne
fermons pas les frontières on l'a eue
fait par la suite et à plusieurs
reprises et à chaque fois avec l'arrivée
du virus souche et puis les différents
variant que ce soit le alpha du royaume
uni le delta à chaque fois tous les pays
se sont claquemurés et c'est justement
cette panique on veut faire quelque
chose et il faut faire quelque chose qui
soit visible et accepté par la
population
et comme la population finalement se dit
on va s'enfermer derrière nos frontières
ça va aller
on arrive là dedans mais ça montre une
seule chose aussi c'est qu'on est sur
une pandémie pandémie sémantiquement par
l'onss et qui se joue sur tous les
continents et aujourd'hui vouloir
traiter aujourd'hui comme hier et demain
j'aurais dû dire traiter une pandémie au
niveau national c'est une hérésie c'est
perdu d'avancé en fait ça ne peut pas se
faire autrement que par une coopération
internationale et ça c'est vraiment le
véritable échec de ces deux dernières
années
[Musique]